TIME IN THEIR INAUGUST RAL
SEASON.
AND WE GOT A HAND PASS IN THE
OFFENSIVE ZONE.
SEATTLE WAITING FOR
GOING.
BURIED, REDIRECTS IT HOME OFF
THE BOOT OF LEON DRAISAITL! STI.
SKATE, S TIME ST.
LOUIS BLEW.
HITS THE LINE THROUGH NURSE.
A BACKHANDER AE LITTLE MOVE.
HE KNOCKS THE STICK AWAY
THERE IS NO MATCH TO.
NICE LITTLE SAUCE PASS ONTO THE
TA
TONIGHT THE 35th OF HIS
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE
TRACKED BY SCHWARTZ.
HE LOOKS UP ICE.
LOBS ONE AHEAD.
NUGENT-HOPKINS.
DRAISAITL BARRELS THROUGH ONE
COMING IN.
HIS BEST STOP OF THEAN KEITH MAA
DELAYED PENALTY!
FEW GAMES AND SNIPPING AROUND
THE NET GETS HIS FIRSTD CLEARED.
AND THAT CRAWLED OVER THE STICKY
THE SEATTLE CAPTAIN.
WRIST SHOT, SAVE MADE! GIORDANO.
YAMAMOTO PRESSURE CAN SHOOT.
THAT DONATO ON THE WENNBERG.
15 ON THE POWER PLAY FOR
MCDAVID.
DRAISAITL WITH 16.
DRAISAITL TWO GOALS AND AN INJUS
OVER THEO
FINDS HIM LATE RIGHT ONTO THE
TAPE AND FROM
ONE TOUCH OVER TO MCDAVID.
ACROSS TO CECI.
YAMAMOTO STACKED IN FRONT.CURRE.
A QUICK DISH OFF TO
PUCK THROUGH LAUZON'S SKATE.
SHORE SHARP ANGLE.
BY KYLE TURRIS!
AND THE FOURTH LINE THAT PUCK AT
RIGHT ON FOR HIS
MAGNIFICENT CAREER.
RETURN OFFERING TO BRAN AND A H.
FAKING THE ONE-TIMER BOUCHARD
>> Louieie
HE NEEDED THAT ONE!
OFF. GOT IT!
BEAUTIFUL LITTLE BACKHAND TO
FOREHAND TUCK FIVE